of uncertainty involved in in
traveling. When a person
travels, they're essentially
leaving their element. They're
leaving their place of
residence. They're leaving
their city. They're leaving
their they're leaving people
that they their network and so
forth and they're leaving that
to go to a place that they're
not from. They're not living
there. And so there is a level
of vulnerability that goes
along with traveling. This
vulnerability induces stress.
It induces anxiety,
apprehension, and foreboding.
Due to this, the people
pre-Islamic Arabs. When they
would travel, especially when
they would travel or undergo
any major event or any major
thing that they would endeavor
to do, they would do what is
called the some of them would
visit soothsayers and fortune
tellers. Some of them would do
what is called al Islam, what
is referred to in the Quran is
Al Islam which is to basically
kind of a question in your mind
and then draw draw sticks that
had certain things written on
them and based on what they
would draw, what they would see
on these sticks. They would do.
also, they would be very
hyper vigilant to any omens,
any ill omens. So, if they
would leave for instance and be
on on their way to travel, they
would be to scan for omens. If
they would see a lizard or if
they would see a bird or
something. They would watch the
movements of this creature and
if it went right for instance,
they would take that as a good
omen and continue their travel
and if it went left, they would
go home. They would consider
that a bad omen. We have
similar things you know, in the
west, every place has them
really. This is due to a
Shaitan teaching people to have
bad of Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and to rely on things
that have no no bearing on
reality. So, for instance, a
person may travel and when
they're on their way to the
airport, maybe they see a car
accident or maybe they hear
something or see something that
unsettles them or maybe a black
cat crosses in front of them or
something of this nature. These
things are impermissible for a
person to to make their
decisions based on. A person
makes his decisions based on
two things. Number one, they
collect information and educate
themselves and seek the wisdom
of others in undertaking any
endeavor and number two, they
make a stickhara, right? So,
the prophet prohibited us from
a he prohibit us from doing any
of these superstitious acts or
may allowing these
superstitious things to have
bearing on our actions. Rather,
he commanded us to engross
ourselves thoroughly in the
issue that we wish to proceed
with to ask the people who have
knowledge or wisdom in that
particular in that particular
field and second of all, two,
to make So, if a person is
going to travel for instance,
they shouldn't look at
nonsensical things that are
superstitious and they'll have
anything to do really with
their travel. They shouldn't
look for black cats or car
accidents or ominous statistics
or bad news or things like
that. Rather, they should do
things check the weather,
right? They should do things
check the traffic check
the prices, whatever it is.
Look at the crime rates of the
place they're going to. Look at
what they need to watch out
for. This is this is all part
of right? Second of all, they
should make two raka and this
is what is called as the is
what Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
replaced all of those
superstitions for us with. So,
he replaced these omens and our
hearts with the so we collect
information, we make a
decision, we make and then we
proceed. One thing I'd to
mention about that often times
is misconstrued. The way that
is works is the prophet said,
that
[Silence]
Allah
be disappointed with the
result. So, a person is to
consult of consulting is that a
person learn as much about the
issue as they can. Say a
person, let's make it easy.
Someone wants to buy a house
for instance and part of
consulting is not only asking
people who are, you know, well
versed in whatever it is having
to do with the purchase of this
home but also looking into
things the neighborhood
and the crime rate and looking
into other things, you know,
trying to gather as much
information about this home as
they can. of all, they make a
they make a
and the way that a person makes
his is as the prophet said, a
person makes two raka, right?
And then after that, they make
a particular dua that the
prophet taught us. This
narration is in Bukhari, a
Muslim on the authority of
Abdullah.
And person sticks to exactly
the wording that is in this
dua. When a person makes this
dua, they proceed with whatever
they feel in their heart, they
should proceed with. If it's
for them, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala will cause them to be
able to attain it. If it is not
for them, then it will be out
of reach for them. And in the
dua, a person makes dua and
prays to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. That if it is not for
me, please
you know, take it away from me
and replace it with something
that is better and please me
with that which you have,
compensated me with. So, this
is how works. Many people think
that or when you make it,
you're supposed to see a dream.
You're supposed to have a dream
of this particular thing. So,
you make a and then you sleep
and then you should see
something in the form of a
dream. That's not how works. It
it's possible. It's possible
that a person may make a and
then have a dream about it,
right? With with some kind of
guidance in it. But that's not
necessarily the norm. And
that's not necessarily what a
person should expect. Rather a
person should make the dua and
then proceed. Another thing,
[Silence]
the
one time, a person makes in the
following fashion. They are to
make as completely and properly
as they came. Excuse me, as
they can. They are to stand
before Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala, make two raka that are
not of the obligatory salah,
meaning optional prayer. During
this salah, they should have
their heart filled with hope
and Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
They should make the salahs
properly as they possibly can
with as much focus in turning
to Allah and concentration as
they can muster. After they
finish
After they finish this salah,
they should make the dua that
we mentioned and after that,
they should proceed with
whatever it is they've whatever
conclusion they've arrived at.
This is this is how it should
properly be done.
[Silence]
get onto and mount his ride
whether it's whatever animal it
was when a person gets in car
or gets in the airplane,
whatever it is. He would make
[Arabic recitation]
then, he would make a dua.
Starting with a verse from the
Quran. He would say
and then he would make the dua
and this dua is found in the
books of Dua, the one that we
always refer to is a fortress
of the Muslims, very good book
[Silence]
cycles or
airplanes or what have you.
That's when the prophet would
place his foot into the ring,
you know, get onto the animal.
He would say bismillah and then
when he would settle on top of
his riding animal, he would say
Alhamdulillah. So, the same
thing if a person gets into his
vehicle, when he opens the door
and puts his foot in, he says,
bismillah and when he settles
into the seat, he says, and
then he would make the dua that
we mentioned
and the Dua for writing is a
little bit different than the
dua for traveling. So the Dua
for writing is as we mentioned
Bismillah. when you get into
it. Alhamdulillah. the